yeah hello and welcome to this video no
other sorts okay I don't want to pre
move 96 very often it would be okay but
sometimes not so much hmm yeah I'd like
to okay I want to make this my main move
here Knight f6 the positions are just a
little bit more interesting and after
Bishop c5 but it's a bit risky for me
because I don't know that the lines with
95 that well this I'm reasonably
comfortable with yam k our thang ed6
they very often play a for now hmm ok
I'm going for that f5 plan which is I
think quite okay but also a little bit
dicey 93 now yeah i had this on the port
and earlier games okay don't quite
remember how that turned out
in wenatchee a tester is the Quan second
way of doing things I mean the did was
the plan so I go for it is that some
default coming or what is the point here
wow I'm surprised that he allows Bishop
g4 in this position that looks like a
very awkward pin I'm actually
threatening 94 now so I think he has to
to do something about that he doesn't
interesting
hmm
yeah I wonder if he wants to see want to
sacrifice the queen or something out a
94 b 5 is also move here Bishop takes 94
but then he might actually now he might
go for the for the Queen sec so I'm just
taking this
now it's doing this okay so i think i'll
go here and now k Bishop g5 now let's do
this so that i can get rid of the
bishops and then i have queen h4 want to
go yeah want to go there get the Queen
ears skin or in this risking side and
King position is it's quite weak so if I
think I think I'll take this there is
night 'if I've also now and I don't
think that something like Queen h5 is
doing that much first of all I'm
threatening f3 he has to do something
about that if I get an F 3 then this
pawn looks like the nail in the coffin
in a way
a difficult difficult for him don't
don't quite see a good defense f3 is
really a big threat Queen m-maybe queen
age five but it doesn't do that much and
I prevent a 3d but I have g6 for example
and then Queen h3 it doesn't inspire
much confidence either yeah this is
running into 95 but maybe he wants to
sacrifice the rook we'll see yeah yeah
that's a that's a that's an idea at
least him muddy the waters a little bit
but I finally get my night back back
home back go back into the game okay
I don't mind trading it's 46 I put on an
exchange up that's not so bad they don't
need to win by can find attack or
something Queen takes us night c7 I
unfortunately have to take with this but
I don't think it's a it's an issue
okay to form okay maybe Bishop d3 24
things I don't know other than that I'm
pretty happy that I've get files opened
him hmm ok let's move the rook out of
the Queen's scope and yeah you can go
Bishop f4 word i'm quite happy to trade
a bishop on g file is not great anyway
oh I have to be a little bit cautious
now not to stumble into night g6 and
stuff like that ok I think I'll just
take the this keep it simple method okay
how to do this Queen f6 maybe get Queen
g6 in the mixin your queen g6 is now a
queen trade yeah come on this is
probably the way to play it without
giving him any any sort of hope for for
swindles on the king for example okay so
so check the pawns t25 I can take if I
can take this 192 is also know what
reason i have a link one yeah I she
simply didn't didn't react to my Bishop
g4 idea I think this is i have seen
before probably also in games that i
have posted on the channel and I five
know it was the idea okay it takes takes
yeah and now a five I think it's just
wrong allowing Bishop g4 seems wrong to
me that I'm able to inflict this damage
on its porn structure this is what the
engine wants to play with I don't really
don't really believe that this this can
be good for white now meanness and his
King position isn't great the only thing
is I'm my pieces are not yet very active
so it's not that I can just quickly win
by checkmate or so but hmm it still
doesn't feel right to me yeah this yeah
I now be five I saw the movie 5 is
giving us winning by the engine I saw
the move but I was not totally convinced
if he may be can do this you know the
Queen sacrifice that I mentioned
something like that wasn't totally
wasn't totally sure about this it looks
a bit scary but probably there's nothing
serious going one if he takes this I can
go here this is very important I am
winning a piece here yeah as always I
only calculated up to here or
alternatively this is also move and I
wasn't totally sure if this is maybe
something this is why i discarded b5 and
just took it there ok c 3 preventing 94
so i take we should be five ID i think
black should be fine but i don't think
he needs to get get such a bad position
as he got in the game maybe I Forza it's
a bit too yeah maybe the qsr worse than
the disease in some kind of way and this
is I'm happy about him yeah maybe f4 I
mean thing is I believe that check I'm
better also if it does not play a 4 but
it is so it is difficult as more since
it's trickier to play yeah I don't like
to give up my bishop but when he has got
ideas maybe like this and I don't really
want to deal with this so just take it
and play play simple moves now just go
to the endgame sometimes I'm this kind
of endgame with rook rook and and minor
piece against two bishops can be tricky
because the bishops tend to be strong
but here I'm probably having too quick
over played against the pawns as we saw
in the game here like tempo and it is
attacked again and he's losing one of
the pawns yet d5 I just take this or
maybe this is this is more precise he
never can do this because of check which
is quite important otherwise the point
would be would be somewhat dangerous
yeah ok thanks for watching